[Music]
here we go thank you thank you all right
so last speaking of edc let's play a
game of tattoo roulette and as you can
see we've got our lovely tattoo artists
here about to start the process of
giving me my very first tattoo i'm
getting blasted on live tv i'm so
excited
but kim
excuse me who's excuse me i'm sorry kim
is here of inkbox and he's going to tell
us
actually what's going on here okay so
let us know what inkbox is and what kind
of tattoo i'm getting yeah so inkbox is
basically tattoos reimagined what we're
trying to do is make tattoos more
accessible
so you think about like fashion and
beauty accessories how you can use that
to
change your mood or change your styles
we're bringing that to tattoo artistry
wow and what are you guys doing here in
las vegas for edc weekend yeah so we're
setting up shop at camp edc
and we have the pirate the tattoo cove
okay you can go there our guests can go
there and play tattoo roulette oh my god
and play their chances
and get a tattoo done by a tattoo artist
or they could use our tattoo freehand
tattoo marker and draw and create on
their own oh okay oh wow so you can
actually design your own as well yeah
yeah see what's great about the pencils
yeah what's great about this is that
this puts the power in everyone everyone
can be an artist with a freehand tattoo
blocker if you have any kind of
creativity if you just want a doodle or
make great masterpieces this is a tool
for you awesome okay so obviously at adc
or anywhere you would play tattoo
roulette
these stencils we have here i'm getting
a rose these are pg we have a shell an
anchor a happy face but you can get a
little rated r too right oh yeah we want
them out there we want to make it fun so
we have tattoos that are traditional
tattoos we have some that are irreverent
like the little you know avocado
yeah the tattoo kindle once he was
pushing the avocado um and then we have
some tattoos that are nsfw which is not
safe for work so you know they're a
little edgy maybe not safe for you know
for uh for the news but people are
lining up and so the tattoo reel
gets spun by the crowd and they decide
which tattoo you get by the artist at
the table so it is a luck of chance it's
very vegas right kind of like you know
luck of the draw you're playing people
are rooting for the nsfw like everyone
wants that tattoo because everyone is
just feeling real wild for eating
okay so how long do these last and and
you know what are what are we getting
here what are we getting ourselves into
sure the tattoos last one to two weeks
okay yeah so it's a semi-permanent uh
certainly it's a patented technology
that we develop ourselves it's skin safe
it's vegan
and not tested on any animals okay so
people get worried about getting tattoos
because they think it's unsafe for the
skin but this is totally safe yeah how
does it feel it feels good it's actually
quite relaxing yeah i enjoyed getting
tattoos now i'm worried because after
this i'm going to feel like i need a
real one yeah does that happen too yeah
well people come to us for two reasons
they either want to just use the tattoos
as a way again of self-expression yeah
changing up their style or sometimes
they use us to test out a tattoo that
they might want to think and do
permanent so we have both universes
coming to us but with the freehand we're
finding that people are using this and
not even thinking about getting a
permanent because they just love the
the dynamic the um the instant
gratification they get from doing this
and drawing anything they want and it
becomes kind of like an accessory to
your outfit absolutely right changes
your mood you make a statement depending
how you feel how you wake up that day
that's awesome okay and you guys have
some technology called freehand tattoo
making and you can actually get this on
your website right yes so you go to
inkbox.com
we have three product categories we have
tattoos that are we have 10 000 tattoos
that have been pre-designed by over 1200
global artists around the world wow and
we have a custom tool where you can kind
of like make your own tattoo we'll ship
it to you and then we have the marker oh
that is so cool yeah that is so cool
okay can we can we do a great reveal
here it is what about what did i get
what did i get you got the rose i got
the roll it looks good
i really do line work this is so much
fun i think mom will approve
who mom
you know what yeah i think so she's
watching now i think that's beautiful
see you can get whatever you want with
inkbox okay edc weekend but also
inkbox.combox.com if you want to you
know get into it for your everyday
day-to-day life yeah and if anyone
coming to edc comes to our booth we have
an exclusive offer for anyone who's at
edc we love that yeah what's the offer
the offer is you get a free tattoo which
is edc themes through the famous owl and
you get free shipping on your order of
the marker awesome well thank you guys
so much this is so fun my first tattoo
no reverse right